estos soldados ucranianos utilizan armas
entregadas por francia
todos están muy concentrados mientras se
preparan para lanzar un ataque
uy
tienen los nervios de punta a lo lejos
se oyen disparos de artillería
hecho en francia este vehículo militar
es un obús autopropulsado césar con un
cañón de calibre 52
se utilizan tres para el ataque los
vehículos se alinean y se cargan
disparan contra la artillería rusa
ubicada a 17 km de distancia
después de un momento se puede escuchar
a los proyectiles aterrizar en su
objetivo la operación duró un poco más
de cuatro minutos al terminar los
vehículos se retiran para evitar ser
rastreados y atacados por las fuerzas
rusas la unidad de artillería móvil es
un objetivo importante del enemigo en la
base militar un oficial nos muestra
fotografías de la operación los drones
de vigilancia ucranianos sobrevuelan las
áreas objetivo y siguen cada una de las
misiones de los césar en estas imágenes
aparecen unos tanques rusos destruidos
hace unos días y los soldados que
murieron
ese día fue devastador para el enemigo y
los soldados que sobrevivieron al ataque
trataron de huir y se escondieron en los
árboles
el comandante dice que tiene seis
vehículos césar disponibles y que han
destruido al menos 80 armas de
artillería rusas
fuimos a ver un curso de entrenamiento
que se desarrolla detrás de la línea de
frente
estos artilleros ucranianos primero
fueron entrenados en francia en medio de
la guerra hace un mes
nos enviaron a francia para que
aprendiéramos a utilizar el vehículo
césar había mucho que asimilar tuvimos
que entender todo lo más rápido posible
en menos de dos semanas
tristes bolsa
una de las tareas principales es dominar
la introducción de las coordenadas del
objetivo el cesar dispara 6 proyectiles
por minuto y tiene un alcance de unos 40
kilómetros su punto fuerte en batalla es
su alto nivel de movilidad
el enemigo está utilizando tecnología de
punta y drones para ubicarnos así que no
podemos quedarnos en un solo lugar
durante mucho tiempo
no podemos darle tiempo de responder
y
la ubicación de los vehículos es secreta
solo se conducen por los campos durante
la noche hay 18 en ucrania